ليش ما تعتبرونه دلال دليل دليل ونجاح لهم
بمعنى انهم اناس يملكون الموهبه يملكون
الحضور يملكون التخطيط يملكون التنظيم
وبالتالي يملكون القدره على التجدد بدليل
انهم يعني خلقوا مضامين جديده ومحتوى جديد
غير المحتوى التقليدي للوعظه التقليدي
الذي يقوم بعد صلاه العشاء او بعد قبيل
صلاه العشاء او بعد صلاه العصر ويلقي من
رياض الصالحين للنووي بضعه احاديث وصلى
الله وبارك هؤلاء اناس لديهم القدره ترى
السويدان مهندس بترول متخرج عنده ماجستير
ودكتوراه مهندس بترول هذه يعني كانت ملفته
للنظر ايضا تخصصه في كل مراحل التعليميه
العليا كان في هندسه البترول مع ذلك الرجل
استطاع ان يخترق المجتمع لو لم يكن ناجحا
لم استقبله الناس بهذا الامر هل هذا
التصور صحيح ام ثمه عوامل اخرى في تقديرك
هو ما في شك انهم قدموا خطابا جديدا لانهم
ليسوا فقراء تقليديين لا علاقه لا لكثير
منهم بالفقه التقليدي ولكن الشعار
الاسلام هو شعار سياسي يستخدمونه للوصول
الى اهدافهم واهدافهم صريحه سيطره على
الحكم الوصول الى السلطه بالسلم بالقوه
بالثورات بالقتال بالعنف لا يختلف طارق
السويدان عن اسامه بن لادن لا يختلف حسن
البنا عن البغدادي الخلاف بينهم فقط في
الاساليب او التكتيكات المتبعه للوصول الى
هذا الهدف هذه جماعات عنيفه تستبيح كل شيء
تستبيح الدماء وتستبيح الاموال وتستبيح
الاعراض للوصول الى هدفها كونهم يستخدمون
اساليب حديثه هل نعتبر خالد شيخ محمد
عبقريا لانه عرف كيف يضرب الابراج في
امريكا ويقتل المئات ولم يستخدموا العنف
يعني طارق السودان يعني
قصدي عشان نستحضر لو كان ثمه احد من مريدي
طارق ربما رد بهذه الطريقه يعني السويدان
لم يستخدم العنف ربما فيه او لسياسه مرح
يتغياها وهذه جماعات عرفت ان تفرق بين
تنظيمات السريه والتنظيمات العلنيه بين
الخطاب المعلن والخطاب السري ولكن طارق
السويدان وغيره في لحظه كاشفه تاريخيه وهي
لحظه الربيع العربي كشف عن ما تخبئه نفسه
نفسه نسي كثيرا من طروحاته في التطوير
الذاتي او فيما يسميه هو التغيير عند هذه
النقطه انا لفت انتباهي حين المسند برامجه
التلفزيونيه واللي كانت منتشره الى 2009
كان عنده عده برامج ولكن من اشهرها برنامج
علمتني الحياه من 2011 الى 2012 صنع
برنامجا جديدا في قناه الرساله وغيرها كان
اسمه ازمنه التغيير يعني هنا في تحول ملفت
للنظر يعني من تطوير ذاتي الى ازمنه
التغيير يعني هو قوات السويدان مره بعده
مراحل في البدايه دخل المشهد
كراوي للتاريخ
وخذي اتناول التاريخ طبعا باسلوب
ركيك علميا وحتى ركيك لغويا لانه قدرات
الشخص في العلميه متواضعه هناك
علميه التراثيه طبعا وهو وهو الذي طرح فيه
طرحه وتحدث فيه يعني لا نريد ان نتحدث عن
تخصصه في البترول لكن نتحدث عن الشان
العام الذي دخل فيه فاخذ يتحدث عن
الفتنه الكبرى بين الصحابه ويتحدث
في هذا الاطار ويفصل باسلوب الدعاه الجدد
في في العالم العربي المستقى من الدعاه
الجدد في الغرب
فجذب الكثير من الناس لعده اسباب منها انه
عقيده اهل السنه والجماعه والمسلمين لا
يتحدثون فيما شجر بين الصحابه هو الرجل
ذهب وتحدث وتحدث
بجهل عجيب وغريب يعني ليس بالاحداث
التاريخيه
وبالمواقف لا يمتلك ادنى قدره على التحقيق
والتمحيص التاريخ بل انه يخطئ في اسماء
الاعلام يعلى بن اميه يسميه يعلي وليس
لديه احد يعني يصحح له هذا الخطا ولذلك
قبلت محاضراته في بدايه التسعينات تقريبا
باستهجان كبير من قبل التيارات السلفيه
وتيار اهل الحديث اللي كان منتشر ومتشر في
تلك الفتره بينما قامت كل جماعات الاسلام
السياسي ورموزه وتياراته وهي تنظيمات قويه
بدعمه بدون استثناء
ومنحوه الانتشار الذي وصل اليه